une production du studio SF
bienvenue au sans filtre le podcast où
on parle de ce qu'on veut que nos
invités date 7 je pH Quentin avec moi
Doom plant excellent podcast cette
semaine très belle conversation très
bonne conversation
c'est du podcast de haut niveau
avec qui avec un ruba Gazal qui est
député pour Québec solidaire qui va se
présenter à l'automne pour devenir
copains de Québec solidaire remplacé si
on veut même cité elle est irremplaçable
Manon Massé on a parlé vraiment de plein
de sujets différents beaucoup
d'immigration beaucoup de comment en
fait
elle-même est issue de migration
d'origine palestinienne né au Liban
en fait elle nous a raconté son
processus à elle d'immigration ici
lorsqu'elle avait 10 ans comment sa
famille le véhicule puis comment que on
peut en tant que société puis comment
qu'on doit en fait
accueillir l'immigration comment et
comment
qu'on gère ça la gestion de la langue la
gestion de l'unité de la culture
québécoise dans ce contexte-là c'était
vraiment super intéressant on a parlé de
ces propositions en tant que ces idées
en fait en tant que futur peut-être
potentiels
[Musique]
l'indépendance du Québec de quelle façon
est-ce que ça pourrait se faire
l'indépendance du Québec sous quelle
forme ça pourrait peut-être prendre ça
pourrait prendre en fait puis aussi de
leur patriar sur l'amour du Québec en
fait qu'on a fait quand même
l'importance de la culture
non mais
[Musique]
on le dit dans le podcast c'est quand
même précieux d'avoir le Québec dans le
monde il y a le jeu ça la langue
québécoise la culture québécoise il y en
a une
jusqu'à ce qu'il y en a plus c'est ça
puis il y en a une qui est belle puis
est unique puis c'est une parmi tant
d'autres dans le sens que des cultures
aussi belles calculs québécoises il y en
a plein mais c'est le c'est la nôtre
c'est là c'est notre devoir de la
protéger
si tout le monde fait ça peu importe sa
culture essayer de garder ce vivant
c'est de garder ce qui fait de notre
unicité
vivant ben ça fait un monde où est-ce
qu'il y a plusieurs unités plein de
beauté qui est une infinité de choses à
découvrir puis de différentes manières
de voir le monde à découvrir versus si
on fait juste écouter les mêmes
émissions américaines puis parler la
même langue américaine
à quoi ça servira même de voyager toutes
les couleurs du monde ça va puis le
monde pourrait devenir brun ça serait
triste mais ça serait très cools sont
tellement belles dans toute leur teinte
dans toute leur variétés puis ça c'est
deux idées là cette idée-là puis l'idée
aussi
d'être ouvert à l’ailleurs puis à
l'autre ces deux idées qui parfois
peuvent sembler contradictoires mais
quelque chose de l'inverse pas du tout
parce que le meilleur exemple de ça puis
on parle la différence entre
multiculturalisme et interculturalisme
le meilleur exemple d'interculturalisme
au niveau de la culture c'est des Colocs
les colocs c'est un des bandes les plus
marquants de la culture québécoise mais
c'est un
[Musique]
amalgame énorme de plusieurs cultures
mais dans le concept dans le contexte
de la culture québécoise qui maintenant
c'est un pilier fondateur de notre
culture fait que de penser que pour
conserver la culture québécoise c'est
dire non à l'autre c'est pas ça c'est
d'enseigner à l'autre quel est notre
culture qui peut y amener de la sienne
et de l'adapter puis de faire presque ça
se met à morceau tout le temps ça évolue
tout le temps si c'est ce qui fait la
beauté c'est juste va quelque chose de
nouveau versus vers juste quelque chose
qui est une pôle copie de ce qui fait ce
qui c'est au sud
ça ça serait triste tout à fait moi
aussi ça c'est une des affaires qui me
râle plus triste quand je pense à ça il
y a tellement
de manière de voir le monde au Québec
puis il y a tellement de beauté dans les
arts mais juste dans notre langage dans
notre dans notre dans nos idées dans la
comment qu'on rayonne à l'international
c'est précieux c'est vraiment précieux
sur ce
podcast de cette semaine est présenté
par menscape encore et toujours toujours
présent à chaque fois on essaie de vous
présenter de quoi d'un peu différent
même si ça reste du même Skype puis là
ben aujourd'hui on décide de parler du
2.0 la version 2.0 donne mes outils
préférés le widworkers c'est un
incontournable m'a fait son essentiel
parce que en fait ça va
s'attaquer à quelque chose qui est
souvent négligé souvent trop souvent
puis c'est c'est important de partager à
ceux qui sont les poils de nez les poils
dorées aussi moi c'est surtout une
problématique de poil de nuit que j'ai
pour ça que j'ai besoin de mon bon
widwalker qui a des sacline des fois des
fois ça m'arrive de revenir un fixe
comme le poil trop long nez qui sort le
carrément déconnecté je suis plus
conversations je suis plus là tout ça à
cause d'un si la personne c'est pas de
ma faute c'est de ça
notamment le 2.0
si vous voulez vous procurer le waywaker
2.0 ou quelqu'un ça c'est quelqu'un dans
votre vie que il y a des temps les poils
nés vous êtes gêné de dire que des poils
de nez partez de Noël vous le piger
organisez-vous avec le gars des vues
pour le pigé au bureau là il y a chez
Louis Walker 2.0
[Musique]
n'importe quel autre produit man Skype
les meilleurs produits au monde vous le
savez on en parle tout le temps utiliser
le code promo sans filtre ça va vous
faire sauver 20% de rabais plus la
livraison gratuite et ça va leur
indiquer que vous y allez grâce à nous
donc ça nous encourage aussi merci à
vous et bon podcast bonne écoute
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
merci d'être là
session parlementaire qui vient de
terminer comment ça va c'est que tu es
comme vraiment les vacances comme
scooter c'est un peu comme oui les
enfants la dernière journée là on est
tout excité on prend des photos comme si
on veut plus jamais se revoir de toute
notre vie alors qu'on va savoir au mois
de septembre mon livre de fin d'année
qui amène leur bébé au Salon bleu puis
c'est on est vraiment c'est quand on est
au Salon bleu là à l'Assemblée nationale
on a tous si on entre entre 10 et 15 ans
ouais c'est pour ça ok ça explique les
effets sur facebook la présente pour
dire est-ce qu'il va neiger aujourd'hui
les enfants calmez-vous on est vraiment
énervé quand on est au Salon bleu puis
on notre âge on dirait pas que c'est des
parents puis des adultes qui sont ici je
sais pas ce qui se passe mais c'est toi
que du monde responsable en dehors du
salon
clairement de ce que nous nous serons
jusqu'à nous des échanges au Salon bleu
puis à l'Assemblée nationale tout le
temps
de camaraderie inter partisane
dans les corridors par exemple moi j'ai
un dossier je veux parler avec quelqu'un
d'autre de l'opposition ou même un
ministre un député qui pourrait
influencer un ministre de la CAQ on le
fait on a toutes nos textos on se texte
puis si par exemple il y a quelqu'un je
suis pour moi on sait que c'est sa fête
ou quelqu'un dans sa famille vient
d'avoir un enfant c'est on se parle
normalement à l'extérieur puis une
camarade risque que vous voyez là dans
les médias c'est
peut-être 5% là de ce qu'on fait pour
vrai
non c'est toutes des êtres humains pitié
on
en tout cas j'ai des bonnes relations
avec tout le monde c'est sûr que des
fois c'est plus dur par exemple si tu as
un échange très très corsé avec un
ministre de sortir tout de suite après
on va prendre une bière moi j'ai besoin
de décanter avant de prendre une bière
mais il y en a qui sont plus capables
d'avoir une coupure entre gens à
l'instant c'est comme dès que les
caméras sont coupées par exemple au
Salon bleu là ça s'infective ça arrête
pas les caméras sont coupées et puis ça
je l'ai vu là
comme des sommes des des boxeurs des
combattants qui là ils se parlent pas
plus quasiment il se crash d'en face
pendant toute amenant vers le combat
puis la seconde que le dernier titre le
combat est terminé c'est genre euh
c'est ça ils se prennent moi je suis pas
capable je pense que c'est plus un truc
générationnel c'est générationnel et
aussi d'homme moi un journaliste qui m'a
dit de la tribune de la presse aux
autres il observe la fonte politique
depuis très très longtemps un vieux
journaliste qui m'a dit c'est ça vous
êtes si vous mélangez pas beaucoup je
trouve par rapport à une autre époque où
les gens vont au bar sur la Grande Allée
après c'est en partie ça devient que ça
existe moins aujourd'hui je sais pas
est-ce que c'est l'arrivée peut-être des
femmes aussi en politique c'est une
autre façon on va moins au bord parce
que il y a toutes sortes de choses qui
peuvent qui restent d'arriver on fait
attention je ne sais pas mais moi je
pense qu'il y a un truc générationnel
aussi et homme femme c'est moi c'est pas
un jeu quand j'interpelle le ministre
Bernard drinville par exemple moi je
suis responsable en matière d'éducation
j'ai déposé un projet de loi pour
contrer les pour prévenir les codes
agressions sexuelles si on a eu beaucoup
dans les médias les jeunes qui sont là
dans ces écoles là c'est des mineurs tu
sais ça devrait nous scandaliser mais
quand j'interpelle le ministre je
m'interpelle avec tout mon coeur tout ce
que je ressens puis j'ai le les yeux des
jeunes filles qui m'ont parlé c'est
quelques jours avant puis c'est ça que
j'apporte à l'Assemblée nationale fait
que c'est totalement vrai je suis pas
capable après ça de parler avec le
ministre comme si de rien n'était mais
peut-être quelques jours plus tard si
j'ai un dossier par exemple dans mon
comté pour une école je suis capable de
lui parler de le texter normalement fait
que ça chose saine et logique dans le
sens que c'est que vous êtes là pour
défendre vos idées c'est normal que
soyez pas
meilleure amie en sortant d'être là en
tant que ça est différent fondamental
sur des sur des sur certaines affaires
tout à fait c'est notre façon de voir
les choses peut-être des fois il les
gens par exemple à la cas qui sont 90
députés ils sont pas 90 personnes
d'accord à tous les instants de ce que
chacun fait il y a quand même il faut
respecter la ligne de partie puis si ça
peut être bon aussi pour la cohésion
mais après ça probablement qui ont des
moments où c'est très tendu comme dans
tous les cocus ou les gens se parlent et
tout ça puis après ça à l'extérieur ben
l'ennemi entre guillemets c'est l'autre
partie mais il y a quelque chose il y a
comme quelque chose d'un jeu Catherine
Dorion disait que c'est comme une
mauvaise pièce de théâtre
parce que les acteurs sont pas très bons
parce qu'on n'est pas des acteurs quand
tu vois moi
qui était meilleur que
les jokes chez plus quoi que des fois ça
peut être au Salon bleu mais c'est on va
pas en politique pour faire un show
médiatique
c'est moi si je suis en politique
aujourd'hui je pensais pas moi je suis
une militante dans l'arbre c'est
vraiment mon modèle c'était Françoise
David donc qui était à la Fédération des
femmes du Québec quand j'étais
adolescente à l'époque dans les années
90 je la regardais à aller puis après ça
je me dis une un jour si cette femme-là
va en politique moi elle m'inspire c'est
au-delà des idées de de lutte contre les
inégalités de s'assurer que tout le
monde là puisse savoir c'est tous les
enfants peu importe leur milieu peu
importe où est-ce qu'ils sont nés qui
puissent avoir droit à tout puis avoir
une belle vie au-delà des valeurs c'est
aussi les gens qui les portent puis
c'était ma source d'inspiration mais
c'était pas pour nécessairement devenir
une députée c'était pour pour changer le
monde puis l'améliorer par rapport je
reviens encore sur la question de la
joute de la game parce que ça me faisait
passer je pense que Jean-René du fort
qui avait raconté ça une fois puis
disait qu'il fallait-il rencontrer Jean
Charette pour
pour une capsule pour quelque chose et
puis il venait de sortir de la famille
nationale puis
[Musique]
noir sur une affaire je pense avec
Pauline Marois puis terre rouge
[Musique]
c'est ça c'est ça reste le paysan tu
avais pas trop on fait nos affaires
parce que je veux dire ça dépend des
gens euh
moi d'autres personnes je suis certaine
ne sont pas capable de dire ah ok je
mets
je suis comme dans un joute juste pour
en mettre plein la vue aux médiocre que
je peux savoir une clip le soir
aux nouvelles puis après ça je peux
passer à autre chose c'est pas aussi
clair que ça mais en même temps comme
une façon de se protéger de test
important pour nous comme députés de
toujours se rappeler pourquoi je suis là
je suis pas là juste pour faire un show
puis pour montrer ça dans les médias
c'est la grande majorité de mon travail
ça se fait derrière les caméras parce
que dans mon bureau de comté avec des
citoyens je rencontre des parents qui
sont frustrés d'une d'une décision qui a
été prise par un centre de service
scolaire qui va faire que leur frais de
service de garde vont être très élevés
c'est pas il y a rien de pour appeler je
veux dire je suis en train de parler
avec eux puis j'essaie de trouver des
solutions j'interpelle le cabinet du
ministre c'est surtout ça notre travail
la grande majorité du temps puis après
ça il y a un show mais c'est pas faut
oublier que ça c'est juste une partie
parce que c'est le système politique ou
médiatique qui est fait comme ça moi
j'aimerais ça le transformer le changer
mais faut choisir ses priorités mais on
pourrait passer si on regarde juste les
les médias ou les réseaux sociaux de la
manière que tu es un parti
inévitablement un autre sur les idées
que
qui n'aurait pas tantôt des Canada
camaraderies en partie mais il y en a
quand même un peu finalement il faudrait
peut-être les montrer des fois ils font
des reportages
qui veut montrer que il y a quand même
une camaraderie il va avoir un reportage
de temps en temps mais le quotidien
c'est pas ça parce que les médias ils
cherchent eux aussi sont concurrence
puis ils veulent survivre c'est le
modèle change qui cherche la clé donc
c'est ça qui marche moi je pose celle
qui contribue le plus aux clic parce que
c'est pas capable de dire en une phrase
punchy tout ce que je veux dire puis que
je veux dire j'essayerai je suis pas
capable j'ai pas de talent pour ça fait
que mais il y en a qui sont bons
là-dedans c'est eux qui attirent les
lumières
comment je regardais pas
quand même relativement près la la
session parlementaire comment les
projets de loi sont déposés puis comment
est-ce qu'on
de la Société des trucs qu'on juge qui
sont qui ont pas de bon sens mais qu'au
final on a pas vraiment d'impact mais
c'est on vit dans une démocratie c'est à
chaque quatre ans qui a des élections
donc tu sais le gouvernement là
maintenant oui il est arrogant il se
peut il semble être il est arrogant il
sait qu'il a la majorité et monsieur
Legault est en train de tout passer les
affaires qui lui font qu'ils font mal
paraître en début de législature c'est
fait exprès parce qu'il veut pas faire
ça avant 2026 élection avec nous c'est
sûr que nous c'est un grand la job de
potion c'est des formes je suis là si je
terminais
on l'est pas fait qu'on peut juste faire
des propositions puis attirer
l'attention aussi du public sur ce qui
se passe par exemple tu parles des
salades des députés c'est si Québec
soldat on n'était pas là il y en aurait
pas eu de discussion
à me donner un journaliste qui aurait vu
hey il y a ce projet de loi là qui
viennent de se voter ça en catimini ça
aurait fait peut-être les gens ont été
indignés un soir ou deux après ça c'est
terminé fait que nous on a fait ce
travail-là qui de nous opposer dans
l'objectif d'attirer l'attention du
public pour dire voici comment le
gouvernement est en train de le faire
puis comme partie d'opposition on a des
moyens parlementaires puis le moyen
parlementaire le plus important qu'on a
c'est le temps fait on attend de minutes
pour parler d'un sujet tous les autres
partis ont décidé de pas utiliser leur
temps et on dit nous on a rien à dire
nous on est d'accord avec le projet de
loi on avance avec le nous on débattait
un petit peu seul un petit peu Simon
Genin barrette le leader du gouvernement
qui portait le projet de loi en a parlé
un peu fait que ça a fait parler fait
que ça a quand même fait bouger quelque
chose on a aussi demandé un sondage qui
démontrait que trois Québécois sur 4
était contre la façon aussi qu'on
accorde la l'augmentation donc ça fait
de bouger les choses fait qu'on a
utilisé ce qu'on possède comme
opposition pour faire bouger les choses
faire ça c'est quelque chose qu'on peut
faire en démocratie qui est bien
maintenant
malheureusement malgré tout ce qu'on a
fait le gouvernement était décidé à
aller de l'avant et c'est terminé c'est
vrai qu'on peut dire à quoi ça sert tout
ça mais il faut se rappeler que c'est
faut faire confiance à l'intelligence du
des gens c'est moi je pense que les gens
vont s'en rappeler nous on va s'assurer
qui s'en rappelle on va en parler de ça
c'est un exemple pour ce qui est du
logement c'est sûr que ça va pas passer
comme lettre à la morte lettre à la
morte comme Blade remorque à la poste en
tout cas
de savoir je suis pas familier
donc une fois avec la souris c'est comme
non
la sortie maintenant il y a beaucoup de
locataires qu'il y a d'autres pour eux
c'est important ça comme moyen là
session de bail mais on va revenir en
septembre puis on va travailler sur le
projet de loi puis on va faire notre
travail de position tout en se rappelant
que dans 4 ans il y a des élections puis
aussi moi par exemple si je prends d'un
point de vue personnel
c'est important de sortir de l'Assemblée
nationale c'est important de pas rester
juste là dans la bulle c'est des gens
comme vous vous êtes informés vous
suivez ça nous on le suit encore plus on
suit le commentariat mais c'est pas ça
le Québec puisqu'il se passe
il y a d'autres choses puis des fois
l'air de l'Assemblée nationale c'est il
faut sortir de là parce qu'il peut être
difficile puis à un moment donné on
oublie on devient déconnecté comme je le
disais moi je porte le dossier éducation
à la dernière législature j'avais le
dossier langue j'allais encore j'avais
fait une tournée d'une enfant de la loi
101 pour aller voir comment ça se passe
au-delà de toutes les chicanes sur la
langue à l'Assemblée nationale comment
ça se passe la francisation des imm je
suis allée en Outaouais je suis allée
dans des organismes à Québec dans le
centre du Québec j'ai le dossier
éducation pour pas juste savoir ce qui
se passe dans ma revue de presse le
matin en buvant mon café mais je suis
allé j'ai fait une tournée des régions
je suis allé à Trois-Rivières
chamonicans dans body fleuve
Rivière-du-Loup en Italie aussi dans
plein d'endroits pour aller visiter des
écoles des projets où ça se passe bien
des à la ruche à Magog où est-ce qu'ils
ont décidé que eux là le système
d'éducation qui est très inégalitaire au
Québec c'est-à-dire que tu as des
enfants qui sont dans des classes
régulières où ils ont pas de d'autres
projets que juste les cours normaux
souvent c'est des enfants qui ont des
élèves le secondaire primaire qui ont
plus de difficultés en grand nombre
après totalisant les élèves un peu plus
avec des meilleurs notes que les parents
un peu plus d'argent sont à l'école
publique mais avec des projets
particuliers intéressants comme par
exemple si par études pleines
l'école privée mais seul le gouvernement
veut pas le j'ai interpellé Bernard
drinville à plusieurs reprises il existe
un système à trois vitesses qui recréent
les inégalités économiques qui existent
dans notre société alors que notre
système d'éducation est exposé faire ce
qu'on appelle des transfuges de classe
que des gens qui viennent de mieux
pauvre puisse aspirer à devenir ce
qu'ils veulent dans la vie et puis faire
des grandes études et le ministre il
veut pas il veut pas que moi ce que je
fais c'est que je m'en vais par exemple
dans l'école à l'école la ruche je suis
une école secondaire une polyvalente qui
avait mauvaise réputation à une certaine
époque ou des profs ont décidé depuis 7
ans de dire ben nous là on est tanné de
voir que les élèves qui ont des projets
particuliers qui viennent de milieux
plus défavorisés dans notre école ne
soit jamais mélangé avec les élèves ou
leurs parents en arrachent plus on veut
changer ça même si le gouvernement veut
pas bouger pour que ce système là arrête
et prendre de l'argent par exemple des
écoles privées qui sont subventionnées à
hauteur de 75%, puis de les mettre dans
le système public nous on même si le
gouverneur veut pas faire ça on va pas
attendre on va nous-mêmes faire des
projets pour tous les élèves qui soient
bons ou pas bon à l'école pour qu'ils
puissent se mélanger puis on demande pas
d'argent fait que c'est pas eux-mêmes
qui ont fait ça mais moi c'est des
exemples inspirants que je vais voir sur
le terrain puis qu'après ça je rapporte
à l'Assemblée nationale ça me permet de
ne pas être cynique puis dire que ben il
y a des choses qui se font puis je fais
ma petite contribution à sachant que il
y a une limite quand on est dans la
position c'est mon truc à moi mais je
comprends
juste de ce que tu viens de dire parce
que moi c'est un sujet qui m'intéresse
non seulement qui m'intéresse mais qui
font qui me préoccupe en fait comment ça
se passe la francisation des immigrants
parce que on en parle à fond la caisse
on lance des chiffres de capacité en
France en accueil mais en français tout
le monde a son propre chef personne
d'étude concrète de capacité comment ça
se passe dans le terrain de ton
observation mais c'est une très bonne
question parce qu'on ne le discours sur
l'immigration puis après ça la réalité
comment ça se passe des fois on a
l'impression mon Dieu le Québec est à
feu et à 100 ça fait du bien de voir que
il y a plus d'ouverture puis plus de
choses intéressantes qui se passent mais
avec des problèmes maintenant pour ce
qui est de la francisation c'est moi par
exemple je suis une enfant de la loi 101
ça veut dire que quand je suis arrivé au
Québec vous étiez pas né à la fin des
années 80 j'avais 10 ans et je parlais
pas le français je suis arrivée avec ma
famille mon frère mes soeurs personne
parlait le français puis moi j'ai été
dans une classe d'accueil et j'en visite
des classes d'accueil ça me touche
beaucoup là quand je vois ça les les
enfants je me retrouve là je me
reconnais en eux il y a 35 ans ça me
touche faites aux autres ils vont être
francisés oui c'est facile parce qu'on
ils sont plus jeunes ceux qui arrivent
plus jeunes mais il y a quand même des
défis puis il y a beaucoup beaucoup
c'est les profs qui disent il y a des
enfants qui viennent avec des troupes
parce qu'ils ont vécu des traumatismes
dans leur pays mais il y a quand même la
francisation se fait pour maintenant
pour leurs parents le je sais que le
gouvernement de la CAPAC c'est vrai ils
l'ont dit là puis des fois faut le
reconnaître quand le gouvernement fait
des bonnes choses ils ont mis plus
d'argent que les gouvernements
précédents en francisation mais c'est
pas suffisant c'est à dire que quand un
immigrant qui arrive par exemple lui il
veut devenir permanent là je parle même
pas des temporaires les temporelles
c'est un autre sujet fait que
personne semblait s'entendre dans les
dernières semaines de l'Assemblée
c'était c'est un sujet très important
parce qu'ils sont comme 300000 au Québec
là en ce moment là effectivement on
prend par exemple l'immigration comme
moi quand je suis arrivée avec ma
famille où on voulait rester ici on
voulait s'établir mais là à l'époque il
y avait un programme qui existait du
gouvernement qui a été coupé au début
des années 2000 c'est un programme qu'on
appelle les copies lissantes
d'orientation de francisation faites-le
les gens ils travaillent pas ils
reçoivent une petite compensation puis
là oui après le français en classe mais
ils vont faire des sorties pour
apprendre c'est quoi la culture au
Québec ils vont aller au jardin
botanique tout ça c'est un peu plus
large ça ça existe plus mais les gens
qui vont suivre des cours de français
que ça soit dans une commission scolaire
ou avec des organismes communautaires là
eux vont avoir un petit peu ce métier
c'est à dire qu'ils suivent le français
mais il travaille pas il reçoit une un
petit peu d'argent c'est beaucoup moins
que le salaire minimum sauf que les
immigrants quand ils veulent quand même
mettre du pain sur la table des enfants
fait dès qu'il y a un emploi puis qu'il
trouve qu'il y arrive plus avec
l'inflation c'est un peu difficile mais
souvent ils vont quitter leur cours de
français qui vont aller travailler
souvent les immigrants par exemple c'est
là j'ai pas de chiffres le pot à vous
donner mais par exemple à Montréal s'ils
vont aller dans des entreprises de de
leur par exemple moi je suis dans une
Palestinienne arabe libanaise là je vous
raconterai ça plus tard mais c'est par
exemple ils vont aller dans des dans des
commerces où ça parle en arabe la mesure
était des clients sont arabes il y a des
latinos c'est en espagnol factice ça se
prend six pas
sur le marché du travail faites pour ça
que nous ce qu'on propose ça existe pas
vraiment ça veut dire que ça existe mais
ça dépend des employeurs nous à Québec
soldat puis moi j'y crois beaucoup c'est
au lieu que les gens ne gagnent pas
d'argent pour avoir des cours de
français le soir ou le jour mais que la
France là sont sur les heures du travail
mais que ça soit ça devienne obligatoire
là en ce moment il y a des employeurs
qui sont des bons employeurs qui donnent
des cours de français plus ils ont une
petite partie qui est compensée par le
gouvernement pour leurs employés sur
leurs heures du travail et tout ça mais
il faut que ça soit soutenu c'est un
petit peu puis en ce moment c'est pas
obligatoire pour les employeurs de le
faire fait que les gens qui sont pas
chanceux qui sont pas francisés dans
leurs heures de travail faut que je
trouve l'énergie de soi
c'est là que ça se fait moins malgré
l'argent que le gouvernement a mis c'est
pas suffisant il y a même par exemple à
Québec des immigrants qui veulent suivre
des cours mais il y a des listes
d'attente pour pouvoir avoir accès parce
que la demande est très grande pour les
cours de français
les gens qui travaillent mais ça devrait
être dans le milieu de travail qui peut
se suivre leur cours ça ça serait ça
c'est une des propositions que à Québec
soldats ont fait puis de le rendre
obligatoire puis que les employeurs
mettent on est en punir une main
d'oeuvre mais qui paye aussi qui veulent
avoir de travailleurs maintenant les
migrations temporaires c'est beaucoup
plus compliqué aux autres ils viennent
ils parlent pas français puis le
gouvernement est pas pressé de les de
les de les franciser parce qu'ils sont
supposés temporaire mais il y en a qui
sont temporaires pendant des années des
années puis leurs enfants quand ils
arrivent ici là ben c'est pas des
enfants de la loi 101 ils peuvent aller
à l'école en anglais parce que parce
qu'ils sont pas sont pas tenus si ils
sont pas se poser rester fait on a toute
une grande partie de l'immigration 300
000 que le gouvernement
n'en parle pas trop dit c'est pas de ça
qu'on parle nous le chiffre tu disais le
chiffre au début c'était 50000 en haute
chose ça devient suicidaire
il est en train de faire des
consultations mais là on regarde une
petite partie de gens alors que les
immigrants temporaires qui arrivent en
grand nombre qu'on prend 6 pas mais qui
travaille mais on a besoin d'eux comme
malheureusement comme main d'oeuvre
c'est alors qui ont d'autres
contributions à faire dans la société
mais il y en a qui après ça veulent
devenir permanent mais là ça fait
quelques années qui sont ici il y en a
qui ont pris le français d'autre pas
fait c'est bordélique disons parce que
ça ça m'apparaît comme le nord de la
guerre le tire des gens qui viennent ici
un peu un peu dans l'idée que c'est
qu'on est en Amérique du Nord dans le
fond qu'on est Toronto ou New York c'est
la même surtout Montréal je veux parler
de l'exemple précis de Montréal là où
est-ce que
le monde vient ici pour travailler de
façon temporaire puis il traite comme
s'il arrivait à Toronto ils veulent
comme le on dirait le collectivement on
a une belle société au Québec sauf que
la raison que laquelle on a une belle
société au Québec parce que
culturellement on est québécois
essentiellement le tu veux comme venir
dans la culture québécoise mais en le
traitant comme Toronto puis ça je trouve
ça je trouve c'est quand même c'est ça
qui me dérange le plus souvent
d'arriver n'importe où
au Canada en Amérique du Nord exactement
on leur envoie quand il arrive c'est par
exemple il y a des gens qui viennent de
l'Afrique du Nord ou de l'Afrique mais
eux le français s'il parle aussi bien
que toi et moi
y arrivent puis quand ils viennent sur
le marché du travail ben oui on demande
le français mais de plus même beaucoup
on demande de prendre le savoir parler
anglais moi je connais une dans mon
comté il y a une âme elle est d'origine
algérienne et elle travaille dans le
milieu dans l'entreprise pharmaceutique
puis elle a une expertise vraiment
reconnue recherchée
de le parler fait que j'arrive en
entrevue ils ont besoin de mon expertise
il me pose des questions en anglais je
leur dis je procure de parler en anglais
mais je vais vous je comprends ce que
vous dites je vais vous parler en
français Bella job elle l'a pas est en
train de partir sa propre business une
entreprise qu'elle fait qu'elle part
parce que elle elle est francophone puis
elle est pas capable de travailler parce
qu'elle a pas une connaissance de
l'anglais à Montréal c'est ça exactement
un problème moi-même mes parents quand
on est arrivé ça on est ma famille a
vraiment choisi Montréal
pourquoi le Québec tu sais parce que
c'est une question qui revient souvent
mettons moi ok pourquoi tu es ici c'est
quoi que tu veux
pas dans le sens
mais genre pourquoi tu as choisi ici la
réponse c'est pas parce que c'est le
moi je me rappelle très bien de cette
conversation là qu'on a eu avant
d'arriver au Québec je vous ai dit je
suis arrivé j'avais 10 ans et demi l'été
88 donc on compte encore
très important puis quand je suis arrivé
dans juste avant parce qu'on savait
qu'on allait venir ici comme de façon
permanente on avait beaucoup beaucoup
d'amis des amis de mon père de ma
famille qui était aussi d'origine
palestinienne on habitait aux Émirats
arabes unis dans le golfe Persique là
c'était même pas vraiment de notre pays
faites-le mes parents ben pour eux ils
disaient ben on a beaucoup d'amis qui
vont à Toronto mais là avec mes farines
disaient mais au Canada il y a Toronto
puis aussi Montréal fait que moi dans ma
tête d'enfants que je connaissais pas
très bien la géographie c'était le
Canada c'est Toronto ou Montréal puis
Toronto ça se passe en anglais si
j'avais une petite base en anglais mes
parents parler vraiment langue plus
l'anglais puis évidemment la langue
maternelle c'est l'arabe mais après qui
ont dit mais à Montréal c'est anglais et
français et là on a dit ah mais on a la
RAM on va prendre ça on va devenir
trimestre c'est sûr qu'il faut aller à
Montréal même si on avait moins d'amis
je rappelle il y avait juste un couple
d'amis parce que c'est important quand
timing dans une place de te retrouver
avec
la même chose de vous aider n'importe où
dans le monde là puis vous allez trouver
de base par les experts les Québécois
qu'on rencontre à l'extérieur
ensemble exact c'est normal que les gens
fassent la même chose ici mais on a
choisi ça pour le français sauf que les
immigrants puis c'est comme ça dans la
tête de mes parents dans la tête de tout
le monde quand ils viennent au Québec
ils viennent pas au Québec ils viennent
au Canada puis le Canada arrive avec un
discours
ultra accueillant et ultra-jean vous
pouvez vivre comme vous voulez comme si
vous étiez dans votre pays mais ici avec
la pipe tous les avantages alors que au
Québec c'est comme il y a quand même pas
de plus qu'il faut que tu fasses
c'est oui tu vis comme si on respecte ce
que d'où tu viens parler ta langue c'est
la langue à la maison moi quand je vais
voir je vais plus chez mes parents là
mais quand je vais voir mes parents on
parle en arabe c'est vraiment juste en
arabe avec ça on s'en fout là ça vient
pas menacer le français puis notre
culture et tout ça puis moi si je suis
fière de dire que je suis d'origine
palestinienne puis je l'ai en moi parce
que j'ai vécu avec ça dans mon enfance
puis je veux pas jeter ça mais en même
temps ça ajoute la culture québécoise
puis un pote plus à faire pourquoi parce
que le Québec n'est pas un pays puis là
c'est là que ça devient maintenant dans
la tête des gens c'est des immigrants
puissent mettre alors à leur place
surtout quand ils viennent parler avec
n'importe qui puis là il parle avec un
français un peu cassé là tout de suite
nous qu'est-ce qu'on fait on change on
switch en anglais on change en anglais
puis là ça aide pas mais ça c'est plus à
Montréal pour apprendre le français faut
aller ailleurs au Québec fait que ça
c'est sûr que ça va toujours rester
cette
cette concurrence entre le fédéral et le
Québec où est-ce que nous si on a notre
culture ici au Québec notre histoire qui
est différente il y a des gens qui
viennent qui ont pas la chance de venir
enfin comme moi puis de pouvoir
l'inculquer
dans les années formatrices exactement
construisant mon identité ça s'est fait
petit à petit je peux devenir québécoise
en mettant le pied sur le tarmac ça a
pris des années et puis je peux juste
devenu québécoise puis je parle français
je veux dire je me sens 100% Québécois
j'adore se payer là je sais que jamais
j'aurais pu vivre ma vie de de femmes
libre et tout ça si je suis resté dans
nos pays d'origine fait que je remercie
mes parents de ça mais c'est pas évident
parce que il y a cette concurrence de
l'anglais il y a cette concurrence de
cette ambiguïté là qui vient que le
Québec n'est pas un pays indépendant qui
va toujours faire en sorte que les
immigrants ça va toujours rester confus
malgré toutes les lois qui disent que la
langue le français ça la langue
officielle est commune tout ça ça va
rester puis moi j'ai des fois je me dis
il faudrait que c'est oui faut que notre
message soit soit clair puis une des
façons de l'aide ben c'est de dire ben
au Québec le Québec c'est pas le Canada
mais en ce moment légalement c'est pas
c'est pas le cas on peut pas reprocher
aux gens qui viennent de dire ben non on
est au Canada cette discussion là je
l'ai des fois avec des membres de ma
famille parce que moi je crée toujours
le pont entre les deux je me suis calme
dans les dans la avec ma famille pour
dire c'est quoi le Québec puis ma
famille qui sont plus récemment arrivés
puis après ça je me suis calme par
exemple avec des amis de la majorité
pour leur dire c'est quoi les immigrants
qu'est-ce qui vivent parce que je
comprends ce qu'ils vivent c'est aux
autres ils arrivent au Canada ça reste
solarité le passeport québécois
faites-le puis c'est difficile de le
comprendre c'est à part de de
à part de faire comme je dis une façon
de s'intégrer si on n'est pas allé à
l'école en français puisqu'on n'était
pas été un enfant de 81 mais il faut
c'est par les amitiés par les pensées de
Noël dans une famille typiquement
québécoise aller à la cabane à sucre
quand même sauf que écouter la télé
que francophone québécoises mais même
les jeunes l'écoutent plus personne
le plus grand scandale de l'année
justement ce processus-là de
francisation d'intégration je veux dire
il s'est fait
mais maintenant mais tes parents aux
autres qui étaient déjà comme ils l'ont
vécu leur arrivée ici en fait eux c'est
difficile mes parents ils ont vécu puis
je suis sûr que ce que je veux dire
représente les parents d'immigrants ils
ont vécu ce que aujourd'hui les
Québécois ressemblent des Québécois
peut-être d'un certain âge qui disent
qui ont peur puis avec raison
parce qu'un jour on va continuer à
parler le français ici en Amérique du
Nord il y a comme une crise québécois
même pas de de plusieurs plus âgés
que je me questionne beaucoup sur ça
c'est quelque chose qui me crée
l'anxiété aussi beaucoup tu le
questionnes je vais continuer à répondre
mais je suis comme curieuse toi tu leur
sens c'est qu'est-ce qui fait que tu
leur sens
anecdotiques mais c'est des anecdotes
qui restent longtemps avec moi je veux
juste donner un exemple puis là tu sais
c'est vraiment encore une fois c'est
super anecdotique le tu sais mais
l'autre jour je suis sur Notre-Dame ici
danser en réunissant quartier industriel
francophone le type de quand même
ouvrier francophone sur Notre-Dame dans
un restaurant oui c'est un restaurant
indien qui que je volais avec ma sœur
puis le serveur vient me voir puis il me
demande
puis là je le regarde puis d'habitude
pas que je fais une scène là mais tu
sais genre je décide de juste dire je
vais prendre un verre d'eau tu es de
répondre en français mais pas faire
comme si il me dérangeait de me parler
en anglais je fais un verre d'eau s'il
vous plaît là je me retourne puis là il
me regarde il fait sorry je dis un verre
d'eau genre juste un verre d'eau plus il
fait comme tu comprends pas là je le
regarde puis là dans ma tête je me dis
bon c'est
c'est pas le problème c'est pas lui
non mais peut-être mais en même temps
tu es à Montréal quand tu travailles
comme serveur puis là je te mets ton moi
le premier mot que j'apprends qu'en
jouant en voyage c'est haut c'est comme
un besoin assez de base là puis là il
est parti puis c'est un autre un autre
serveur qui est venu qui parlait
français des anecdotes comme ça
maintenant que ça s'additionnent
peut-être dans un souper
comme le souper j'étais au souper
graduation ma sœur était à l'université
de Miguel en médecine toute façon
surpris de graduation anglais partout
puis je comprends mais c'est université
à Montréal quand même des gens
francophones autour de la table il y a
des gens francophones qui me parlent à
moi en anglais puis que là pour comme
que tout le monde soit un peu intégré je
parle en anglais aussi tu sais puis
c'est des petites anecdotes comme ça qui
ont fait que quand après ça je retourne
à Québec celui-là moi j'habite à Québec
depuis un an maintenant je retourne à
Québec là j'ai fait ok non il y a
quelque chose qui se passe à Montréal il
y a quelque chose qui se passe
du tout du tout partout ailleurs
chacun j'en reviens ici je me dis ok non
il y a quelque chose qui se passe là
c'est une assez grande ville une
métropole énorme qui risque de
progressivement
ce prendre de l'ampleur si ça commence à
Montréal ça va éventuellement éviter
longtemps que j'ai commencé aussi c'est
juste que là on en parle plus mais c'est
ça me fait peur parce que moi je suis
extrêmement attaché à la langue
française je fais de mon parcours en
littérature puis j'ai ça me fait
vraiment de la peine mettons l'autre
fois je me suis à pleurer dans mon champ
parce que j'écoutais
c'est quoi j'écoutais le don de Jean
leloupe je pense pas que tout le monde
doit connaître le dôme ou peu importe
mais je me disais un moment donné il y a
quelqu'un ou peut-être même c'est déjà
arrivé quelqu'un qui naît dans une
famille francophone en ce moment qui est
une famille francophone un jeune de
en 15 et 20 ans c'est adolescence qui
probablement
soit jamais entendu cette chanson là ou
si je lui faisais entendre fréquent
ce jeune là il y a d'autres c'est
d'autres artistes francophones
toi comme une crise
identitaire
mais mes parents c'était la même chose
quand ils sont venus leurs amis disaient
parce que tu sais moi je viens aussi
d'une famille qui est musulmane donc
c'est une autre culture fait que là puis
on connaît on connaît le monde
occidental les gens qui sont pas de mon
occidental connaissent très bien de mon
occidental parce qu'il est très très
présent la partout
c'est un monologue là c'est pas un
dialogue c'est pas un dialogue leurs
amis tu leur disaient oh mais là va
falloir vraiment que vous conserviez
votre langue votre culture votre
religion fait que comme une pression en
fait quand on est arrivé là mes parents
c'est comme c'était très conservateur et
très je crois pas assimilé mais c'était
exact mais c'était pas comme ça je veux
dire si on est intéressé dans notre pays
aurait été un peu plus relax ouais mais
là sur toute faite puis ça a été comme
pinou comme on est enfant en devenant
adolescente mais ce qu'on veut c'est
être comme toutes nos amis ressembler à
nos amis toutes ça quoi que moi j'étais
à Montréal puis après ça je suis allé à
Laval puis il y a beaucoup beaucoup
d'immigrés qui étaient comme un petit
peu comme moi des adolescents mais
faites ça ça a été ça a été quelque
chose de de difficile mais même mes
parents il a fallu après ça qu'ils
comprennent où est-ce qu'ils sont puis
qui prennent ça un peu plus relax mais
c'est un cheminement qui prend du temps
puis moi-même quand je suis c'est toute
mon adolescence en même temps que
j'apprenais
la culture québécoise que j'allais chez
des amis québécoises que je regardais la
télé watata ça vous connaissez
l'archéologie
ou le après l'école on avait des cours
qui étaient payés par le gouvernement
d'arabe parce qu'on avait beaucoup
j'étais à Ville Saint-Laurent là le haut
mais à une autre époque mais quand
j'étais là il y avait beaucoup d'Arabes
avec eux ils voulaient il savait même le
mystère l'Éducation du Québec voulait
qu'on apprenne bien notre langue
maternelle pour être pour après ça être
bon en français plutôt quand on
l'apprend le jour fait que là je sais
plus c'était quoi la question à laquelle
je répondais mais ça a pris du temps
c'est comme ça prend du temps la
construction qui il faut que la société
d'accueil accepte ça par exemple le
monsieur qui te répondait qui était pas
capable de répondre et tout ça c'est
tu as raison de dire c'est pas lui qu'on
attend
un système c'est à dire qu'il y a tout
un discours où le gouvernement dit le
faut être fier de notre langue et tout
ça après quand on leur dit ok mais il
faudrait imposer ça aux entreprises vont
imposer ça au Big Boss de Air Canada
pierre Canada qui s'est fédéral il
pourrait d'excuse mais les dépanneurs là
ici le couche tard si tu regardes les
composition des du conseil
d'administration c'est une information
que j'essaye d'avoir c'est combien qu'il
y a des gens qui parlent qui sont qui
parlent français autour de la table ceux
qui prennent les décisions peut-être que
ça aussi ça perdole sur la société fait
qu'on impose quelque chose dans le
discours mais après ça dans pour
certaines personnes ben c'est comme deux
pots de mesure par rapport à la langue
française au Québec j'ai l'impression
que une spécificité qui a été comme une
double posture parce qu'on est en même
temps qu'on est majoritaire au sein du
Québec en tant que francophone on est
vraiment minoritaire au sein de
l'Amérique du Nord en tant que
francophone versus anglophone facté on a
cette position là de minorité dans le
contexte américain ou est-ce que la
culture est
omniprésente culture américaine ici on
écoute des Netflix on écoute puis on est
de plus en plus americanisé comme peu et
en même temps on ne la majorité l'offre
francophone
qu'il faut aussi avoir cette ouverture
là puisque de conscience là de qui des
gens qui arrivent ici qui sont des
minorités qu'on est une majorité on est
à la fois une majorité inévité c'est
comme si
des fois on a l'impression les gens qui
se il y a comme dans le discours là
comme par exemple la CAQ va dire on est
pression que nous on est une minorité
c'est puis il faut toujours se rappeler
qu'on ait une minorité donc il faut
qu'on se protège contre ceux qui
viennent parce que sinon c'est
suicidaire il y en a qui travaille pas
après ça il s'excuse là comme si vous
voulez on se rappelle de cet épisode là
qui a été comme vraiment blessant même
pour moi qui est ici depuis toujours je
me dis comment les jeunes sont en train
de percevoir ce message-là pas du tout
accueillant qui a ça puis après ça il y
a les gens qui disent ben non on est une
majorité ça moi je suis d'accord moi je
me dis qu'on est les deux qu'il faut je
sais que ça ça peut être alien non c'est
parce qu'on est quoi qui sommes-nous
mais on est aussi une majorité puis
c'est pas vrai au Québec là je veux dire
on décide de beaucoup de loi
pas tout on n'a pas tout là c'est pour
ça que moi il faut l'indépendance puis
c'est pour toute le projet de Québec
soldat la protection de l'environnement
la justice sociale etc on a besoin de
tout ça puis moi c'est pour ça que je
suis indépendantiste mais une des
raisons aussi c'est pour que cette crise
là qui existe tout chez les Québécois on
est une minorité c'est pas vrai on est
on est les victimes de l'histoire mais
en même temps oui mais on a plein de loi
qu'on peut faire pour changer les choses
on est une majorité aussi qu'il faut
l'assumer que ça vient avec une
responsabilité c'est moi je me dis que
si on était indépendance ça serait plus
simple plus clair et ça serait bon pour
tout le monde même pour les minorité
dans la culture québécoise exactement on
aurait comme des responsabilités puis on
serait pu en train de dire oh mon dieu
il nous attaque et tout ça puis parce
que les Québécois on aime ça que les
gens nous aiment tu sais on aime je le
sais le thé on aime ça être aimé c'est
mieux j'aime cette attitude là
que d'être de penser que on n'est pas
chauvin au Québec mais en même temps ben
c'est quand des gens nous c'est pas
toutes il faut pas qu'on s'effondre
qu'on dise on est ça devient comme une
crise nationale ben oui il y a des gens
qui vont être racistes envers les
Québécois mais ça empêche pas que on est
quand même une majorité puis on peut on
a des responsabilités face aux minorités
qui viennent ça c'est comme c'est comme
une un truc qui est pas intégré puis une
façon de le faire c'est d'avoir par
exemple une politique ou une loi sur
l'interculturalisme l'interculturelle
c'est en réaction en réaction seulement
là mais c'est une réponse aux
multiculturalisme c'est à dire que le
fédéral e ils ont une loi s'écrit dans
une loi que c'est le modèle
multiculturel puis la raison à l'époque
avec Trudeau pair c'était de dire mais
les Québécois c'est une culture
parmi toutes les autres c'est pour
diluer ce qui était on était plus c'est
une coupure avec les deux pops
fondateurs mais l'interculturelle qui
une autre façon de voir si
Bouchard qui est prophage Chicoutimi
donc il y a comme 80 aujourd'hui puis
qui écrit beaucoup lui il dit il
faudrait qu'on ait une loi qui dise ben
nous c'est l'interculturalisme puis
souvent il y a des gens un peu plus de
la tendance de la cave ou de la droite
identitaire qui disent c'est pas vrai
l'interculose c'est pareil que le
multiculturelle mais moi je dis que
c'est faux donc si longtemps qu'on n'est
pas un pays il faudrait qu'on ait un
modèle concurrentiel par rapport au
Canada pour pas que les jeunes
immigrants quand il entendent le
discours de fermeture des fois de
Monsieur par exemple le goût ou c'est
suffisant ses affaires là ben il est
jeune ils ont juste envie d'être
canadien et on prend envie d'être
Québécois tu sais même si leurs amis
sont québécois alors même s'ils parlent
français puis moi ça j'ai peur moi ça
m'inquiète beaucoup faites le modèle
interculturel c'est dire il y a un sac
commun ou dans l'espace public c'est en
français c'est la culture québécoise ça
c'est comme la pâte autour le tronc
autour duquel quand on est ensemble
quand on va camper ensemble quand on va
manger ensemble quand on va n'importe où
mais il y a quelque chose qui
comme vous voulez votre culture c'est
comme si vous avez pas changé de pays
mais si vous êtes au Canada c'est ça
qu'elle le redit c'est le c'est ça c'est
vis ta vie puis comme ça au Québec c'est
pas ça on veut faire société on a un
projet comment ensemble on veut on a une
façon de penser de réfléchir de rêver
qui est différente des autres mais moi
je veux pas que ça soit juste les les pH
Quantin et puis
juste de moi
[Rires]
qui arrivent et envie de se fondre là
dedans puis on le j'ai l'impression que
l'attire par exemple le gouvernement
actuel puis dans un certain discours
ambiant on dit qu'il faut protéger notre
culture et tout ça mais on se donne pas
les moyens parce que qu'on le veuille
pas là des petits triboles ils vont en
avoir plein plein qui en a déjà plein
qui ça va continuer parce qu'on va pas
demander aux femmes de faire plus
d'enfants pour protéger la nation
francophone
de faire ce pont là pour pour l'avenir
du Québec puis de pas ça de pas diviser
le comme tu dis cette tendance là à
l'immigration puis
l'interculturalisme mettons ça en vaut
nulle part essayer de descendre les
seuils d'immigrations je sais pas ce qui
va freiner ce mouvement là ça va
continuer ça arrivera pas on le fera
le Québec on veut on est une société qui
veut
croire qui peut qui veut je veux dire
s'épanouir puis ça se fera pas en ayant
moins de monde c'est la culture au final
puis c'est moi c'est ça le j'imagine pas
mon cheval le batteur parce que je suis
loin d'être
impliqué au point où est-ce que je
prends des idées mais ce que je me dis
c'est que la culture c'est c'est juste
l'accumulation de toutes les cultures
mises ensemble c'est sauf que pour être
capable d'ajouter à une culture pour
bien la comprendre
que si
tu fais juste habiter sur un territoire
mais que tu exact considères pas faire
partie de sa société là mais c'est là
qu'il y a une pizza il faut qu'on mette
en place les conditions pour que les
gens aient envie c'est que j'ai
participé comme moi j'ai eu toutes ces
conditions là il y avait pas je me dis
tout le temps tu sais comme toute le
discours par exemple qui a commencé à
partir des en 2007 les accommodements
raisonnables ou là on montait en épingle
toutes sortes de choses parce qu'il y
avait des musulmans qui priait dans une
cabane à sucre ok mais ils étaient dans
une cabane à sucre
dans une mosquée dans un seul ils
peuvent aussi être dans une mosquée dans
leur sol mais ils étaient dans une
cabane à sucre
ça a commencé après ça y est le chef des
valeurs de Pauline Marois
on se le rappelle puis le discours de
Monsieur boulet puis c'est suicidaire
puis la louisianisation du Québec et
tout ça moi je me dis moi l'homme ma
québécitudes avec petit thé comme
quittait bien c'est bien intégré il y a
personne qui va venir là dessus ah je
veux plus être québécoise parce qu'il
parle quand même puis je trouve ça assez
je peux moi je pue là mais des jeunes
qui sont dans leur processus de
construction
identitaires qui sont en train de
vouloir comprendre leur culture
d'origine pour pouvoir intégrer la
nouvelle parce que sinon on est déchiré
là c'est très c'est très difficile
toutes les enfants d'immigrants
qui ont vécu mais ça c'est un moment
sensible c'est un moment précieux quand
on amène ça dans l'espace public ça
vient ça vient briser quelque chose puis
c'est pas bon ni pour les enfants
d'immigrants et les immigrants ni pour
la société québécoise de façon générale
que notre culture c'est faut mettre
c'est pas juste un truc individuel
est-ce que moi je suis à quelqu'un
d'ouvert c'est là quelqu'un là pour
pouvoir travailler il faut qu'il parle
français sinon il y a pas il pourra pas
apporter de la nourriture à la famille
je veux dire tu demanderas de parler
n'importe quelle langue il va la parler
en ce moment les statut fait pas très
fort surtout à Montréal parce mais pas
ou pas les entreprises de rendre moi
j'avais une proposition que j'ai amené
de rendre obligatoire de mettre de
l'argent même pour la francisation en
milieu de travail tu payes pas pour ça
mais l'argent faut que tu le payes au
gouvernement c'est comme un incitatif
S ou ça s'appliquerait aussi au resto
italien du coin du quartier tu sais
parce que j'imagine
dans les restos italiens mais tu viens
de chercher une grande partie des gens
c'est dans les dans des PME de ce pot
cinquantaine et plus d'employés en fait
en ce moment c'est 25 employés et plus
le que la charte c'est ça la charge de
la langue française la loi 108
s'applique aux entreprises de 25
employés ou plus c'est sûr que les
petits restaurants et tout ça peut-être
que c'est certain que moi j'ai cherché
beaucoup de gens
exact mais si tu as peur de la langue
française la langue française va pas
disparaître dans le monde il y a
d'autres personnes qui la partent mais
ici on la parle d'une autre
mais aussi elle est liée à notre
territoire la culture le sport juste la
TV puis la musique puis la chanson c'est
aussi c'est toute notre façon de vivre
notre territoire à Montréal on le sent
moins mais c'est les grands territoires
les grands espaces aller dans la forêt
c'est quelque chose qui fait partie de
notre culture puis des fois
moi quand on était jeune on n'allait pas
nécessairement c'est faire du camping ça
fait pas partie de la culture de ma
famille tout ça je l'ai fait beaucoup
plus tard ça me fait pas aimer vraiment
le camping mais
ça aussi c'est une façon aussi de
s'intégrer au Québec essentiellement moi
mettons l'odeur de sapin et veut aussi
veut autant dire le Québec que n'importe
quel film québécois pour moi
aussi c'est quelque chose que que si tu
l'as jamais vécu c'est jamais senti
maintenant c'est quoi ça sent le sapin
en hiver maintenant à -25 c'est quelque
chose d'unique quand même
francisation des immigrants
commence pas tout de suite parce qu'on
veut qu'il reste là
c'est une façon aussi de dire on a envie
aussi de protéger notre culture puis
notre territoire puis de le lire aussi à
la question environnementale qui très
très qui nous différencie aussi du reste
du Canada ou c'est un état pétrolier tu
sais pour moi ça fait partie aussi de la
culture puis qu'on
c'est un message qui peut aussi parler
aux immigrants l'idée
l'idée de d'utiliser les régions pour
faciliter l'immigration les capacités
d'immigration comment est-ce qu'on parce
que on en a parlé une coupe de fois sur
le Podcast moi c'est quelque chose qui
me parle beaucoup de ces repeuplé les
régions mais donc comment est-ce qu'on
fait ça si
si les gens qui viennent ici comme tu
disais dans d'autres et tu viens parce
qu'il y a des gens que tu connais qui
sont là puis les gens que tu connais ils
habitent à Montréal puis là tu arrives
dans leur quartier puis là tu crées des
des quartiers
les multicultures mais en tout cas à
l'intérieur de la ville au moins ça
existe pas ghetto comment ça c'est une
on a été préservé de ça préserver des
gâteaux mais effectivement des quartiers
de différentes cultures les gens
viennent ici ils font comme moi pour
ceux qui allaient aller en Gaspésie ça
m'intéresse tu sais qu'en toute mon
monde est ici alors que si tu prends
si tu l'imagines ton le concept de
d'utiliser les régions comme vraiment
aller amener de la richesse dans les
régions amener de l'expertise des de de
la main d'oeuvre de qualité des gens
incroyables qui vont amener aussi leur
culture en région ce qui est pas un mal
on s'entend de diversifier un petit peu
mais pourtours de Montréal c'est
toujours bon comment est-ce qu'on
facilite ça ou est-ce que c'est un
avenir une avenue que que entrevoit oui
mais en fait ça fait très longtemps
qu'on parle de reginalisation de
l'immigration puis personne encore a
réussi puis nous à Québec solidaire dans
différentes campagnes électorales c'est
ce qu'on propose on propose d'avoir par
exemple des carrefours d'immigration et
d'intégration des endroits qui ou tous
les services et pour les immigrants
c'est pour faciliter l'intégration des
immigrants parce que avoir un
travailleur là immigrants ou peu importe
là même pas immigrants qui vont aller
dans une région éloignée il y a personne
de sa famille ou personne proche de lui
où il y a pas de réseau il y a juste
envie de revenir chez lui
on peut pas dire non toi tu es immigrant
toi on va t'obliger à vivre là parce
qu'on est dans une démocratie
donc c'est difficile mais faut avoir des
incitatifs pour que les gens aient envie
après ça pas de rester le seul comme
main d'oeuvre mais d'avoir un réseau
faciliter l'intégration de leur de leur
c'est leur conjoint ou conjointe des
enfants puis c'est pas juste oh il y a
une école enfin qui va à l'école tout va
bien il faut qu'il y ait comme des
organismes et puis il y a des organismes
qui ont beaucoup beaucoup de
d'expérience qui existent déjà dans les
régions puis qui le font mais qui
devrait être encore plus financé pour
s'assurer qu'il puisse répondre aux
besoins des gens c'est comme disait
c'est souvent il y a des gens qui ont un
bon emploi en région tout est bien mais
la famille arrive pas à s'intégrer puis
s'ennuie puis trouve pas ça il y a rien
qui les attache qui ont envie de quitter
faites là c'est de faire c'est des
rencontres familiales des des échanges
interculturels c'est il y a un organisme
ils le font des gens mais il faudrait
comme l'intensifier un peu plus
ça ça se fait si le gouvernement le veut
il peut mettre encore plus d'argent dans
les organismes pas juste au projet genre
à la mission vous là chaque année vous
avez ça de sûr comme montant d'argent
pour que vous puissiez donner les
services
aux citoyens des des entreprises qui
font par eux-mêmes par exemple c'est
dire chaque vendredi il y a un dîner
dans un parc ou pour que les gens se
mélangent puis qui créent le réseau
c'est pas juste un emploi un individu ça
finit là les gens ils n'ont pas juste
besoin d'avoir un emploi et on a besoin
d'une toile d'araignée d'un filet de
sentir que si on a besoin de garder les
enfants chez quelqu'un que ça va être en
sécurité ça c'est comme ça prend tout un
village pour intégrer un immigrant en
région
ça prend une vision c'est qu'il y a des
gens qui s'organisent par eux-mêmes ça
on l'a vu avec les réfugiés syriens avec
les Ukrainiens il y a des gens qui qui
par eux-mêmes lors des communautés un
peu partout au Québec qui ont décidé de
parrainer ces gens-là qui ont construit
ce réseau là qui ont amené des vêtements
d'hiver mais ils font par eux-mêmes les
gens mais il faudrait c'est s'inspirer
de ça que ça soit systématisé partout
avec les moyens pour que pour que ça
reste et que les gens qui vont reste ils
n'ont pas qui quittent quelques années
plus tard puisque les enfants de ces
régions là qui sont nés là kit
effectivement
ça c'est quelque chose qu'on a amené
puis on a chiffré là dans une plusieurs
campagnes électorales à Québec solder
pour qu'on arrête d'en parler puis que
ça devient juste un peu pieux puis on le
fait pas souvent la vision c'est une
bonne job c'est terminé non c'est le
début c'est pas terminé les gens ne
restent pas juste parce qu'ils ont une
bonne job avec un bon salaire exactement
au-delà de la bonne job parce que
maintenant que tu compares la qualité de
vie pour ce que tu payes pour un 4 et
demi ici en région ce que tu dépenses
quand tu vas en région tu es comme tu
vis tu es riche là tu sais puis il me
semble que si tu es capable dans c'est
ça le l'enjeu c'est pas ça parce que
l'enjeu c'est pas c'est pas monétaire
l'enjeu c'est vraiment culturel puis
d'intégration les musulmans on est comme
ça on est des buts sociales si on sait
pas vrai que une job comme je le disais
c'est suffisant puis
moi je me rappelle
il y a plein de gens dans les qui
veulent revitaliser leur région les
Québécois partout là sur le territoire
des illuminunicipaux ils veulent attirer
puis ils veulent qu'il reste puis ils
veulent tout donner aux gens qui sont là
pour comme qui le reste mais ils peuvent
pas porter ça les communautés sur leurs
seules épaules avec un peu de
saupoudrage d'argent du gouvernement il
faut qu'ils aient une vision puis nous
c'est comme ça qu'on a appelé ça dans
chacune des régions il y a des
carrefours pour pouvoir accueillir les
les gens qui qui sont ici puis donner
les ressources pour qu'ils construisent
dans le fond une vie sociale une vie une
vie familiale dans ces communautés là
puis les québécoises sont accueillants
puis en veulent des immigrants puissent
eux que c'est ce que ça prend pour
vitaliser leur région fait que ça prend
pas juste des entreprises ou à qui me
suffit de Steven donne de l'argent voilà
c'est terminé toutes vos après ça comme
par exemple
vitaliser non c'est c'est plus compliqué
que ça c'est plus difficile puis ça on
peut le comprendre si on a été déraciné
c'est moi je le vois moi mes parents
sont arrivés ils avaient à peu près un
petit peu plus jeune que moi aujourd'hui
là j'ai 45 ans c'était fin de trentaine
c'est quelque chose le faire ça là
vraiment c'est juste le goût de quitter
puis tu as peur de perdre ta culture tu
vois que tes enfants et comme des fois
des des il y a eu des difficultés mais
après ça a été comme un modèle de
réussite finalement puisque j'ai envie
que ça continue toujours puis ça se fait
parce qu'on était en sécurité puis on
n'était pas des immigrants temporaires
puis on avait pas une époque d'amoclès
que peut-être qu'il faudrait qu'on
quitte son père notre emploi on venait
faire notre vie ici c'est le genre
d'immigration qu'il faut qu'on favorise
et non pas juste style des gens
précaires moi je pense que en tout cas
j'irai avec toi au restaurant
Le français c'est ça le problème
je changerai de sujet tu as annoncé que
tu vas faire une campagne pour devenir
coparavant prendre la place de Manon
Massé
les énormes
c'est des gros souliers à foncé quand
même parce que j'ai l'impression que
cette femme-là
transpartisan c'est quelqu'un qui
presque universellement apprécié le
titre tu vois que c'est quelqu'un qui
fait ça avec son cœur qui fait ça qui
est resté proche des gens proches du
communautaire ça ça
j'ai pas de question mais c'est ben oui
c'est un fait
pourquoi
je veux dire moi Manon je la connais
avant qu'elle devienne la Manon qu'on
connaît en 2004 je me suis impliqué dans
un mouvement citoyen politique que
Françoise David avait lancé avec
quelques personnes dont manoncé puis je
l'avais vu petit
comment dire si tu peux pas ne pas aimer
Manon dès le premier instant que tu la
vois ça a été là Monsieur comme dans un
assemblée la première fois que je l'ai
vu entrée entrée ce moi je t'ai tout
donné je viens pas d'une famille qui
aime beaucoup la politique là j'avais
envie de m'impliquer puis là tu te sens
vraiment bien puis si elle est restée
exactement la même que celle que j'avais
connu avant puis pour moi c'est une
source d'inspiration puis moi j'ai été
comme militante dans le parti fait que
je fondatrice depuis 2016
puis j'étais militante je me suis
présenté aux élections en 2007 et en
2008 deux fois et j'avais pas gagné
c'était à laurier d'Orient ou Andrés
fantasyla et député puis j'étais
toujours militante fait dans ma tête
j'ai pas une politique c'est moi il y a
un projet de société ambitieux du Québec
qu'on a à Québec solidaire pour lutter
contre les inégalités l'intégration que
l'inclusion pour tout le monde
l'environnement on en parlait moins mais
moi je ne maîtrise en environnement j'ai
étudié j'ai cette maîtrise là au début
des années 2000 à l'Université de
Sherbrooke je travaillais là-dedans puis
je voulais pas juste avoir une job neuf
à 5 en fait je voulais m'impliquer pour
transformer ma société j'avais envie de
ça fait que j'ai contribué à ce parti-là
comme militante puis après ça en 2008
j'ai chaussé des chaussures trop grosses
qui sont celles de Amir Kadir donc Amir
en 2018 qui me disait qu'il allait pas
devenir
prendre un autre après 10 ans je faisais
mon Dieu qu'avec solidaire San Francoise
déjà sans Amir qu'est-ce que ça va être
c'est sûr fait que faites-le moi j'avais
pas dans ma tête que je deviendrai
débuter puis j'ai décidé que c'est tout
de suite j'ai pas hésité fait que j'ai
contribué au parti puis au projet de
société de Québec soldataire comme
député puis là j'ai envie de d'aller
encore plus loin dans ce parti pour moi
c'est comme naturel que de vouloir faire
ça puis je pourrais jamais remplacer
Manon mais j'ai j'ai envie avec mon
bagage tu sais moi j'ai travaillé aussi
dans les en même temps que je militais
dans des entreprises dans des usines
notamment une ici pas loin des shop là
sur bombardier dans des entreprises dans
le milieu industriel comme responsable
Santé Sécurité Environnement fait que
j'ai comme une expérience un bagage de
la vraie vie pas juste de la politique
parce que la politique c'est ça peut
nous c'est un aspect de la vie là c'est
quelques années puis j'ai envie de faire
contribuer tout ça à mon parti que
j'aime que j'ai tatoué sur le coeur
depuis très très longtemps pour moi
c'est naturel
[Musique]
vous m’endiez qu'est-ce qu'on va faire
sans ces pilier là est-ce que est-ce que
vous l'appréhendez le départ de Manon
est-ce que ça reste
peut-être qu'en 2026 elle va se
représenter là je pense pas que c'est
une promesse le mais honnêtement j'ai
entendu qu'elle le dit fait elle reste
comme députée ça je trouve ça vraiment
extraordinaire c'est comme elle a été
quand même aspirante première ministre
au débat des chefs euh
c'est aller députée ça y a pris beaucoup
de plusieurs fois avant qu'elle devienne
députée puis après ça dit mais moi j'ai
envie de venir des petits pides
m'occuper de mon monde dans mon compte
parce qu'il y a forcément besoin c'est
tellement beau mais moi je vais rester
puis je veux laisser la place à la
relève tu sais elle le fait tellement
d'une façon qui est tellement Manon
c'est alors que dans d'autres chefs ça
claque la porte ça s'en va il y a comme
beaucoup d'égo il y a pas ça chez Manon
fait que la façon qu'elle le fait elle
va rester puis c'est sûr que ça va être
d'autres couleurs d'autres relèves moi
je me rappelle quand au début Françoise
quand elle a quitté les gens disaient
est-ce qu'il y a de la relève à Québec
soldat c'était avant que Gabriel Nadaud
Dubois n'arrive puis il y en a puis là
en ce moment c'est ce que Manon dit ben
il y a de la relève dans notre partie il
y a des femmes je suis pas la seule il y
a moins il y a un ils me disent les
artérians Christine Labrit qui sont mes
amis aussi là c'est des collègues de
travail fait que on va faire une course
peut-être qu'il va en avoir d'autres là
c'est pas obligé que ça soit juste nous
trois donc on va faire une course à la
de façon féminine et féministe
en fait moi c'est sûr sur ce moi ce que
j'ai dit aux filles si vous vouloir
qu'on contrôle les gars autour de nous
pour que c'est parce que une course aux
autres tu vois ça comme une game nous on
va faire ça d'une façon solidaire et au
contrat c'est une façon qui va montrer
qu'il y a de la relève passer le beau
parce que s'il y avait personne qui
voulait remplacer Manon on dirait ok
qu'est-ce qui se passe c'est
au contraire puis chacune sa couleur on
va mettre des choses c'est de la vente
qui peuvent être différentes mais au
final on est dans le même parti avec
avec les mêmes valeurs fait que moi je
trouve ça beau pour le débat puis pour
nos membres
au parti admettons que cette course là
est-ce qu'il y a une direction qui
aimerait amener le parti oui
[Rires]
c'est une très bonne question est
incroyable la syntaxe laisse à désirer
vers où direction tu me ramener le parti
c'est comme j'ai la campagne est pas
commencé
mais les choses vont être aujourd'hui ça
commence fin ou puis le vote c'est
seulement par délégué fait que c'est pas
un membre un vote c'est il faut que les
membres deviennent délégués de leur
association locale pour pouvoir voter
fin novembre et moi ce que j'ai déjà dit
pour comme quand j'ai lancé ça il y a
quelques semaines c'est vraiment je
trouve que on a un projet rassembleur à
Québec solidaire et notamment toutes les
questions c'est de la de l'indépendance
de la langue la culture on a des belles
propositions c'est dans notre programme
depuis toujours puis j'ai comme
l'impression que les Québécois ne
l'entendent pas puis moi comme personne
issue de l'immigration qui vient des
minorités ethniques comme on dit même si
j'aime pas le mot une femme racisée
d'origine arabe une famille musulmane
ben si je trouve que c'est important que
ces discours là sur l'indépendance sur
notre ident notre culture soit portée de
façon positive pour que les petites
rubans l'entendent qu'il soit pas
rebutés par le Québec qu'ils aient se
jeter dans les bras du Canada faites moi
j'ai envie que moi qui a une canne c'est
ça que je puisse qu'on puisse l'entendre
un peu plus pour pas laisser ce discours
sur la protection de la langue et tout
ça et de façon Ferté d'un seul côté
exact plus de d'hommes Québécois de
souche qui parle indépendance il faut
d'avoir différents pour paroles de cette
séance j'ai envie de d'amener la team
moi je suis des petites merci donc d'une
successeur de americadir mais aussi de
Gérald Godin Gérald Gaudin qui a été
député du Parti québécois dans les
années
70-80 puis lui dans Mercier il y avait
une grande communauté le matin c'est
juste des franco-français mais il y
avait une grande communauté portugaise
grecque puis lui apprenait leur langue
il voulait c'est pour lui il veut un
Québec moderne pour lui un petit peu en
tout cas
un petit peu ce que je représente
aujourd'hui je suis pas une anecdote il
y a beaucoup beaucoup de gens
issus de l'immigration qui porte le
Québec dans leur cœur c'est comme le
Québec moderne puis j'ai envie qu'on
parle de ces sujets là ça soit plus
entendu ça existe dans notre plateforme
je n'invente rien Françoise et amis
Manon lui en parler tout le temps mais
pour l'avenir j'ai envie qu'on l'entende
plus à notre façon pour élargir disons
les gens qui nous suivent là
c'est partout dans toutes les régions du
Québec puis d'autres choses aussi si je
me questionne beaucoup aussi sur le rôle
de député si vous m'aviez est-ce que tu
trouves que c'est cynique la façon que
ça se passe c'est nous on a deux portes
paroles puis ça faisait beaucoup
beaucoup jaser beaucoup critique au
début quand on a imposé cette façon de
faire c'est parce que Québec solidaire
on va pas juste arriver dans la
politique puis dire oh c'est comme ça
que les institutions ont été faites
depuis 200 ans mais nous on va se mouler
là puis on va rentrer dans le moule nous
ce qu'on veut c'est transformer la façon
de faire la politique la politique en ce
moment c'est une élite qui est décide
des affaires puis les gens en bas alors
que ça devrait être c'est pas une élite
le faudrait que les gens se
reconnaissent une représentation il nous
représente donc il faudrait que les gens
sentent que ça là à l'Assemblée
nationale c'est leur voix à eux ils
n'ont pas la voix d'une certaine classe
privilégiée puis à Québec soldat
remporte ça puis comme on est deux
députés parce qu'on va pas rentrer dans
le moule du chef ou de la cheftaine qui
décide tout mais il y a quelque chose
d'intéressant c'est à dire qu'on peut
amener un des deux pour être plus à
l'Assemblée nationale c'est par exemple
la fonction
d'officier de Gabriel Nanou Dubois
maintenant il est chef parlementaire
avant c'était Manon mais là l'autre
porte parole pour être plus quelqu'un
aussi qui présente sur le terrain mais
qui peuvent venir à l'Assemblée
nationale poser aussi des questions puis
avoir aussi si on veut le l'aspect
médiatique aussi puis ça moi j'ai envie
de fait ça d'être plus la député plus
présente sur le terrain dans les
mouvements sociaux dans les mouvements
de toute la société pour pour qu'on
reste fidèle à ce que Québec soldat on a
un slogan qui dit qu'on est en partie
des ions de la rue mais j'aimerais ça
qu'on l'incarne on l'incarne mais j'ai
envie qu'on l'incarne plus parce que
veut pas c'est toujours comme ça dans
les partis politiques le caucus ou le
Parlement tire le parti puis la base si
on avait émis le membre mais des fois il
y a comme une confrontation on n'est pas
là à Québec solidaire mais moi j'ai
envie qu'on porte-parole d'être celle
qui qui va être plus sur c'est plus sur
le terrain aussi mais j'ai plein
d'autres propositions que je vais que je
vais amener un peu plus sur les
questions des minorités aussi c'est les
minorités ethniques
culturelle la question c'est du
féminisme
puis des régions là suivez-moi vous
allez voir ça la campagne est pas encore
tout à fait commencer
on parle de ça va être la seule question
entier de notre conversation tu parles
de amener la question de l'indépendance
puis la francisation plus largement dans
le parti qu'est-ce qu'on pense de la
campagne que lui ici dans le dans le
Sud-Ouest c'est quoi le comté dans un
contexte ça fait beaucoup parler les
pamphlets Uniland anglophones puis les
non-mensions d'indépendance dans cette
campagne là qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce que
tu réponds à ces
là moi je me rappelle même en 2007-2008
j'avais des pamphlets en plusieurs
langues parce que j'étais à laurier
d'Orient qu'il y avait une communauté
notamment arabe et anglaise en anglais
puis c'était des points fait là unique
c'est une pratique que Québec Solidaire
a toujours eu c'est juste que on les
distribuait pas de façon moi j'en ai
j'en ai fait du porte-à-porte ici pour
Guillaume Kish River fait que on l'a
donné pas c'est juste quelqu'un qui avec
qui qu'est-ce que tu veux c'est la
réalité c'est des citoyens on veut
représenter tout le monde au Québec
faites-le la personne si elle comprenait
pas elle parlait pas français comme fait
le monsieur
en français
québecueil
on lui donne le dépliant puis je l'ai
déjà fait comme je vous le dis c'est une
pratique qui est qu'on a à Québec soldat
et même ceux qui nous ont critiqué j'ai
trouvé des vidéos si je veux dire si on
veut jouer je veux que je déteste
des vidéos c'était en une langue anglais
seulement là du Parti québécois et puis
c'était à l'époque Jean-François lisais
Pierre Paul Saint-Pierre Pôle Emploi
Mondon où il parlait pourquoi est-ce que
les autres ils feraient pas au
référendum en premier mandat ça c'était
l'époque il y a quelques années c'est
des choses comme ça ça existe jusque là
c'est sûr que ça je voulais dire parce
que nous on était fort sur le terrain
puis pour ce qui est de la question de
l'indépendance c'est une partiel fait
que c'est sûr que dans une partiel on
parle des sujets est-ce qu'on aurait pu
en parler plus probablement puis ça
aurait pas je suis sûr qu'on aurait eu
le même résultat
j'aurais eu le même résultat c'est sûr
électorale de ne pas en parler
moi je pense moi je pense pas que ça
aurait nuit honnêtement c'est de mettre
independence sinon en anglais je pense
pas que ça aurait nuit mais souvent dans
les partiels on va mettre l'accent sur
les enjeux parce que c'est pas un
changement de gouvernement on fera pas
le référendum après on fera pas
l'Assemblée constituante tout ça c'est
une partiel puis là on va sur les enjeux
qui préoccupent les gens à court terme
c'est que c'est le logement les
transports c'est beaucoup ça ici là dans
dans le comté fait que c'était ça l'idée
c'est pas une une campagne nationale
maintenant on a eu une campagne en 2022
c'est une campagne nationale puis moi je
le dis on a une proposition qui existe
on n'a pas assez parlé de l'indépendance
puis aussi c'est c'est pas très entendu
c'est à dire que c'est dans notre
plateforme c'est dans notre programme on
a même chiffré combien nous coûterait
faire l'indépendance parce que la
démocratie ça coûte de l'argent
donc nous on a une façon de démocratique
de faire l'indépendance ça c'est sorti
puis elle est présente donc j'ai envie
que les gens l'entende pour pas laisser
laisser ce sujet-là important dans les
mains seulement de d'une minorité de
gens qui ont une autre une autre vision
et un autre projet que celui de Québec
ce discours là indépendantiste auprès de
votre base mettons aujourd'hui c'est
populaire dans le sens que si les gens
vont voter pour nous pour ça je le sais
pas moi je pense que les gens à Québec
solidaire quand on en parle de
l'indépendance quand on parle de la moi
j'ai déjà même fait une vidéo ça je
viens de me rappeler en 2018 pour
qu'avec solidaire en arabe pour
expliquer c'est quoi l'indépendance j'ai
eu beaucoup de bons commentaires en
disant ah c'est drôle personne m'en a
parlé comme ça
c'est populaire quand on en parle c'est
moi je pense que la façon que Québec
soldat on le porte auprès d'une jeune
génération auprès des minorités c'est
populaire quand c'est porté par
quelqu'un qui a à cœur la pour moi la
paix sociale et l'unité nationale moi
c'est pour ça que je veux c'est pour lui
pour nous unir pour nous rassembler puis
pas nous diviser entre fédéraliste
souveraineté Québec soldats ont l'OPI on
le porte il est là je voudrais juste
qu'il soit plus entendu mais
dans le fin fond de toi dans mon fin
fond est-ce que dans mon cœur dans ton
coeur est-ce qu'en 2023 tu crois que
c'est encore possible de le réaliser ce
projet-là oui moi je le crois oui c'est
si on regarde en 95 juste quelques mois
avant le même pas un an le le
l'indépendance leur en termes de
chiffres étaient très très indépendance
était très bas à l'approche de du
référendum en octobre de 95 quand on en
a parlé puis là il y avait eu un débat
puis les gens pouvaient dire c'était
devenu un sujet c'est monté j'ai pas les
chiffres exactement là il faudrait que
je les retrouve là mais c'est monté puis
parce que c'est sûr que quand tu parles
pas de quelque chose bah ça existe pas
les changements sortent de la corde mais
pour devenir une possibilité c'est pas
une possible pas comme un ovni qui va
arriver qui va atterrir c'est porté par
des gens c'est toute la question des
changements climatiques nous on en parle
notre type de réduction de gaz à effet
de serre est très très élevé
avant même qu'on vive la situation
horrible qu'on est en train de vivre des
feux de forêts pour que monsieur le
goodies oups on en fait pas assez pour
l'adaptation au changement climatique
moi je me rappelle en 2019 j'avais une
semaine complète ou tout le cocus
soldats ont posé des questions
uniquement sur l'adaptation au
changement climatique c'était pas
populaire à l'époque si on en parlait
pas mais c'est un sujet comporte et il
faut comme il faut en parler
c'est dans notre plateforme c'est dans
notre programme c'est dans notre ADN
j'ai envie qu'on en parle puis tu es
encore encore plus ces sujets là qui
sont sensibles parce que on peut pas se
diviser moi je moi j'ai peur pour
l'avenir du Québec si on divise
là-dessus puis je deviens je deviens
culturel anxieuse aussi si
comme si on se réunit pas autour de
cette langue de cette ça devient
comment
tu sais moi dans ma tête peu importe que
tu sois conservateur ou progressiste que
tu sois de gauche ou de droite
faisons le Québec puis décidons on est
une nation de quel côté après moi c'est
plus comme ça que je le vois puis ma
question en fait que j'aurais pour toi
c'est comment est-ce que si les deux
parties indépendantistes au Québec sont
quand même
drastiquement éloignés au niveau de
l'identité
au niveau la question identitaire même
si peu importe la terminologie qu'on
utilise pour parler de ça comment est-ce
qu'on arrive à dire ok on s'unit on le
fait on fait ce projet on fait ce
projet-là puis après le projet on
décidera de quel à quel niveau on est
sur sur l'identiteur à quel niveau on
est sur limite ou sur toutes ces
questions là qui divisent le Parti
québécois puis Québec solidaire ça a été
essayé c'est Pierre bourquaud avec lui
Ariane il y avait le rassemblement pour
l'indépendance
nationale donc c'était avant le PQ ils
ont essayé de ce c'était vraiment à
gauche puis on décide de se aborder puis
dire ben on va rentrer dans le Parti
québécois parce que il une seule on veut
faire le pays après ça on se déchira
comme tu dis ça a été essayé puis on
peut pas
il y a plusieurs façons d'être
indépendante c'est correct puis il y a
d'autres nations dans le monde qui porte
l'indépendance puisqu'il y a beaucoup
beaucoup de parties politiques par
exemple je pense à la Catalogne ils sont
pas indépendants mais dans ou en Écosse
et tout ça fait qu'il y a plusieurs
personnes pour pas dire on oublie tout
ça il y a beaucoup trop d'enjeux
importants sur la question de
l'immigration par exemple combien
d'immigrants on amène en ce moment le
Québec peut décider enfin on n'a pas
besoin d'attendre l'indépendance c'est
ça aussi
mais oui parce qu'on vit dedans puis
c'est un impact réel aujourd'hui la
question de changement climatique c'est
le Parti québécois maintenant ils ont
présenté une plateforme tes pros en lien
avec la question des changements
climatiques qui ressemblaient à la nôtre
mais avant moi je me rappelle qu'on
avait d'autres propositions là sur les
voitures électriques ou Jean-François
réalisé en 2018 c'est moi qui est de
nous respecter enfin que ça dépend des
fois on est pour des fois on est proche
d'autres fois non mais il y a des enjeux
sur lesquels on s'entend pas on n'a pas
besoin pour faire l'indépendance de de
d'être un seul parti unique pour ma
question c'était pas ma question c'était
pas est-ce qu'on doit jumeler les
parties c'est ce qu'elle est parce que
je suis d'accord avec toi que ça prend
des représentations en ce moment on
existe dans un Québec qui fait partie du
Canada avec la avec ce qu'on a
maintenant comme système parlementaire
mais comment est-ce que avec cette cette
forme là qu'on a actuellement qui est
nécessaire qu'on doit conserver de
diversité de d'opinion puis de point de
vue puis de politique
comment est-ce qu'on réussit à accéder
à unifier en fait les forces
indépendantistes mais si ça a été fait
en
95 l'Action démocratique du Québec de
Mario Dumont Jacques Parisot pour le
Parti québécois puis il y avait je me
rappelle plus une autre un troisième
coup ça m'échappe mais en tout cas qu'il
y a eu cette même Françoise David qui
était dans le mouvement des femmes
toutes les femmes se sont mises à dire
ben nous pour le 4 pour 95 même si on
n'est pas d'accord avec Monsieur Lucien
Bouchard qui est un peu plus de droite
mais lui il était pas encore Premier
ministre mais tout ça pour dire que
c'était Jacques Parisot en tout cas il y
avait des propositions où ils étaient
pas vraiment d'accord avec le
gouvernement puis on dit tous les
mouvements de la société ont pour ce
moment-là on va mettre de côté nos
différents pour faire ce moment-là qui
va pas durer 5 ans ça allait durer un
vote fait que ça ça peut arriver à un
moment donné quand on s'apais comme
quand on arrive à ce moment un parti un
des un des parties indépendantistes au
pouvoir allez au pouvoir et à Québec
solidaire moi je suis convaincu avec le
talent qu'on a l'efficacité qu'on a à
l'Assemblée nationale dans le parti avec
les discours qu'on porte faudrait qu'on
l'amène puis qu'on le porte plus puis un
jour la CAQ n'est pas éternelle là ils
sont 90 aujourd'hui et puis on a dit non
mais tout
ça se projeter dans l'avenir c'est pour
ça aussi que moi quand je dis que je
veux devenir porte-parole oui je viens
de passer de cette tradition là de
Québec solidaire depuis ses débuts puis
je trouve que c'est important qu'on la
médecine pour se rappeler qui on est
pour qu'on devienne comme tous les vieux
partis puis après ça de se projeter dans
l'avenir puis moi je pense que Québec
soldat en jour va sinon je serais pas là
va être au gouvernement les gens
pensaient même pas qu'on allait devenir
2e groupe de position il y a quelques
années c'est il se moquait de nous quand
on disait fait que moi je convaincu de
ça puis aussi l'indépendance je sais
qu'il y en a qui disent comme Monsieur
Landry l'indépendance n'est ni à gauche
ni à droite c'est toi devant mais
c'est vrai que dans n'importe quel pays
démocratique qui va avoir toutes les
tendances sauf que moi de dire ben je
mets toute le projet de société pour la
justice sociale luth aux inégalités la
question des changements climatiques de
côté pour faire le pays puis après on
verra c'est un petit peu comme les
femmes par exemple qui disent ben
l'important c'est qu'on soit au moins
50% des femmes qu'on ait une première
ministre puis après ça on garde tout
pareil le système patriarcal on va le
garder on va juste nous les femmes se
mouler à ce système là puis on changera
pas l'important c'est le nombre ben moi
ça ne m'intéresse pas comme féminisme
puis en ce moment on voit ce courant là
où les femmes disent il faut qu'on soit
un certain nombre mais on change rien
dans le système moi je trouve que il
faudrait qu'on change Québec soldat
aussi je trouve qu'il est important si
on fait le pays ben je veux pas faire un
pays de droite
est fermée et
conditionnel au fait
ce Québec solidaire arrive au pouvoir
que c'est ok on fait juste on déclenche
juste un référendum si
conditionnement on fait que ça respecte
tel tel tel à faire post référendum si
le oui était accepté tu as combien de
temps encore là pour ouvrir mais éviter
la pour vous expliquer notre projet nous
à Québec soldat qui est peut-être un peu
complexe aussi à expliquer que ça parce
que pendant les élections une mention du
projet ça jamais vraiment été expliqué
là je sais qu'il y a eu un débat parce
que mon nom on dit là Québec soldats
sont juste des maladies si c'est un pays
de gauche après ça le mot
indépendantiste était comme lié à un
Assemblée nationale
officiellement perdu durant les
élections puis moi ça m'a perdu j'ai le
feeling que ça l'obstep perdue d'autre
monde aussi il y a d'autres pays la
Tunisie quand il y a eu le printemps
arabe en 2011 et en fait une assemblée
constituante pour dire nous allons
écrire la constitution de notre pays
parce qu'avant c'est le dictateur qui
disait c'est moi qui décide tout au
Chili aussi en fait la même chose mais à
la fin ils ont comme perdu cette
constitution là n'a pas été portée mais
c'est pas grave il y a eu un exercice
démocratique donc avec soldat la façon
qu'on le dit c'est pas aujourd'hui je
pense qu'il faut faire un référendum ok
aujourd'hui besoin ça marche il y a une
fenêtre dans le ciel qui vient de
s'ouvrir
tout ce qu'on dit c'est il y a il faut
il faut parler de c'est quoi le Québec
qu'on veut en dans ce système de santé
éducation etc puis avoir une assemblée
qui est représentative de toute la
société
même droit de gauche les autochtones
aussi on les oublie souvent le mouvement
indépendantiste voit parle du problème
autochtone alors que ils se sont des
nations et on peut pas faire ça comme
ces existaient pas plein d'avoir une
assemblée représentative de de la
diversité de la population puis après ça
de dire ben ça va être quoi la
constitution d'un pays indépendant du
Québec et là il va avoir un référendum
sur cette question là où il y aura eu ce
débat en 95 il y a eu un débat il y a eu
les gens ils ont reçu un document chez
eux sur le Québec on veut mais tout ça a
duré comme quelques semaines là tu sais
ou quelques mois à peine alors que les
gens ont soif de ça on soit peut-être
que ça va les rapprocher aussi de la
démocratie qu'on parle de quel système
d'éducation qu'on veut quel système de
santé que ça soit pas juste quelques
personnes à l'Assemblée nationale
très bonne question
ben c'est ça ça c'est hypothétique on
sait pas c'est après ça tu sais on n'est
pas il y a pas de non nous ne ferons pas
partie de ça puis nous allons voter
contre c'est impossible quand on regarde
l'histoire comme je le disais là il y a
eu des parties qui se sont mis ensemble
des mouvements sociaux ça a été un
moment extraordinaire au Québec là ou
des mouvements sociaux aussi se sont mis
ensemble pour ce projet-là faites
peut-être que quelque chose comme ça
arrivera ou peut-être pas je le sais pas
je ne connais pas l'avenir je n'ai pas
apporté ma boule de cristal je comprends
mais admettons tu disais tu dises parce
que tu crois qu'il va être au pouvoir
une fois il faut pouvoir si tu me
priorité ça ou c'est ou c'est plus loin
dans la liste des choses accomplir avant
lorsque je suis en train de dire c'est
même pas l'aspirante candidate à devenir
porte-parole féminine notre Québec
soldat nous c'est dans notre programme
et dans notre plateforme c'est de dire
la première chose qu'on fait c'est on
met en place cette assemblée
constituante ça ça va être la première
chose à faire on la met on la met sur
pied parce que c'est un projet
c'est toujours bon en tout cas c'est que
ça serait ça mais en même temps ça nous
empêche pas de faire tout le reste le
plus d'avoir des projets de loi pour
défaire toute le gâcher de la CAQ en
santé en éducation où est-ce qu'il
centralise tout par exemple fait que ça
ça empêche pas de faire ça la question à
l'adaptation au changement climatique on
va pas attendre à chaque fois qu'il y
ait des feux de forêt puis des gens des
réfugiés thématique au Québec on a ça en
ce moment-là
on nous aurait pas cru fait ça ça fait
peur ça rend écho anxieux quand même le
Premier ministre dit qu'il était écho
anxieux excuse-moi je reviens là-dessus
parce que ça a été très très marquant
puis moi je me rappelle très bien avoir
interpellé Benoît charrette sur la
question de changement climatique puis
je le faisais rencontrer des gens depuis
des mois je sais pas et quoi anxieux
mais l'autre en premier Nestlé toi avec
toutes ces affaires là c'est sûr qu'il
va falloir qu'on qu'on les prenne à le
bras le cap qu'on est des lois puisqu'on
est des changements puis des
investissements en même temps qu'il y a
cette assemblée fait qu'on peut pas dire
c'est juste ça puis après ça le reste on
fait rien puis on met le Québec sur
pause on peut pas avoir ça le projet de
Québec solidaire est ambitieux puis moi
c'est pour ça que je suis dans ce partie
là puis on le fait pas de c'est tout
seul on est une belle gaine à Québec
solidaire puis j'ai très très hâte de je
vais continuer à faire une tournée du
Québec avec pour rencontrer les membres
dans le cadre de ma course aussi à
l'automne puis de toute façon générale
tous les députés vont le faire là dans
le cadre d'une tournée où est-ce qu'on
trouve qu'on a pas assez fait par
rapport aux régions là en terme
électoral puis on va aller là où les
gens nous voient moins dans les
différentes régions pour mieux
comprendre puis modifier aussi notre
notre plateforme puis notre proposition
pour 2026 parce que c'est ce
voilà
[Rires]
parce que moi c'est sûr je me disais
peu importe pour qui je voterai ou pour
qui j'ai voté ou peu importe mes
aliments politiques
je me disais l'autre jour je jamais
cette réflexion là en conduisant puis
que si mettons le monde suivait
la politique que moi je la suis c'est à
dire niveau de base mettons là
au niveau médium
par rapport à peut-être que la carte
serait au pouvoir quand même mais ce
serait pas cette
ce serait pas aussi énorme comme gap
entre les deux en comics entre les entre
les parties puis je me disais d'où ça
part ça puis mon impression c'est que ça
part sûrement du monde qui
peut nécessairement le monde en région
mais principalement le monde en région
qui suivent pas ça trop parce que les
intéresse pas c'est bien correct si ça
les rejoint pas je comprends qu'il est
ce qu'on présenter plusieurs choix
politiques puis qui a un des candidats
qui ressemble à leurs voisins parce
qu'il est clairement
pas fait le type où est-ce que les fonds
mais c'est pas exactement c'est quoi le
proposition politique
sauf que je me disais c'est sûr qu'un
travail à faire justement pour un parti
comme Québec solaire énorme de faire
nous on existe aussi puis on n'est pas
on n'est pas Montréal on n'est pas exact
puis je pense que tu l'as bien je pense
que c'est quand même de mon avis de
d'analyste politique de salon ça a été
c'est probablement le plus gros trou
dans Québec solidaire lors des dernières
campagnes j'ai l'impression tu veux dire
le fait qu'on n'est pas réussi à
rejoindre en dehors de Montréal ouais le
fait que ça sonne aucune cloche à
personne en région on le voit à peu près
certaines propositions nous ennuis
surtout en région fait que pitié le
gouvernement il rentrait là-dedans là
sur les VUS
tout le monde a des vives nous on avait
des exceptions maintenant je sais que je
comprends plus qu'une clip de 30
secondes
30 secondes pour expliquer fait que s'il
y a eu des erreurs et tout ça mais
au-delà de ça c'est c'est vraiment oui
tu le dis c'est vrai il faut que Québec
solidaire on peut pas juste faire la
politique assez à l'Assemblée nationale
c'est impossible parce que on n'est pas
à part si on avait un médium un empire
médiatique qui fait tout ce que vous
voulez derrière nous on a pas ça donc
c'est pour ça que moi j'ai toujours
besoin puis je peux la seule puis le
parti aussi nous a dit puis les membres
nous ont dit parce que on n'a pas juste
des moments à Montréal on a des membres
partout à travers le territoire du
Québec des gens qui sont ancrés dans
leur territoire qui connaissent leurs
voisins qui connaissent les gens qui
votent qui savent qu'est-ce qui marche
qu'est-ce qui marche pas dans dans nos
propositions puis qui qui se sont
présentés aussi pour les élections c'est
pas un truc individuel c'est vraiment
collectivement qu'on a pas eu les
résultats qu'on voulait puis ça on
pourra pas gagner ça jusqu'à l'assemblée
nationale c'est pour ça qu'on fait une
tournée puis on va dans les endroits où
les gens nous voient moins de 6 mois par
exemple j'ai travaillé des entreprises
privées là j'ai travaillé oui dans des
grosses entreprises comme bombardier
mais dans des entreprises comme PME et
industriels qui fabrique des choses avec
des gotshop je portais mon ma blouse mon
habit bleu même si j'étais corde là mais
j'allais sur la machine la machine ici
fait attention il faut que tu mettes ça
la sécurité ben ces gens-là sont
syndiqués tout ça mais ou des jeux déjà
très bien dans un endroit donc syndiqué
mais c'est comme le monde qui
réfléchissent qui ont une intelligence
mais qui qui suivent pas la politique
comme nous on la suit puis la suivre
selon leur les briques qui leur arrive
mais ces gens-là faut aller les voir
qui voteraient pas nécessairement pour
nous le gotshop là qui a une qui soudeur
puis j'en ai connu c'est des gens
intelligents que j'ai des belles
discussions puis quand moi j'ai décidé
que je m'en allais en politique puis il
savait des fois les gens de Google et
parce que j'étais là depuis longtemps
vous avez été en politique mais il
s'intéresse il m'en parle ben ça
pourquoi maintenant que depuis que je
suis député je veux juste un certain
type de monde c'est sûr que là je porte
le dossier éducation fait que se voit
plus les profs tout ça mais là il va
falloir qu'on aide un shop d'usine puis
sur le terrain parler avec les gens qui
qui ont une vie remplie qui travaille
très très fort puis qui regarde le gros
bon sens puis là le goût leur dit c'est
moi le gros bon sens qui parle comme un
nom que tu as envie d'inviter chez vous
puis qui comme qui a la fin il est
proche c'est la force de Manon aussi
c'est proche du monde mais ça ces
gens-là ils attendent juste qu'on aille
leur parler parce que quand on leur
parle ben à la fin ça a de l'allure
c'est puis même nous on peut c'est pas
leur dire voici qu'avec solidaire la
bonne parole voilà c'est nous qui avons
raison c'est peut-être
que notre proposition oui elle est bonne
dans l'absolu mais les gens ils ont
l'impression qu'on est en train de leur
enlever quelque chose alors que nous
notre objectif c'est de leur donner
comment est-ce qu'on peut changer ça ben
on va apprendre une ou deux choses en
faisant cette tournée là ça c'est la
sagesse du parti c'est les membres qui
ont dit on veut si vous faites une
tournée on va pas que ce soit juste un
truc médiatique tu es là dans les
régions dans les médias parce que moi je
l'ai fait une tournée puis j'étais pas
dans les médias juste à Rimouski je sais
pas tout d'un coup les gens de Rimouski
Rimouski puis rivière du lourd j'ai fait
un peu de médias mais quand j'ai fait
une tournée pour aller dans les écoles
j'allais juste voir du vrai monde qui
est enceinte je faisais une assemblée
oui il y avait des membres de Québec
solidaire mais si nourrissant c'est du
sang mais on est nombreux là il y a pas
juste les 12 députés là il y a beaucoup
beaucoup de gens pour ça ça faudrait
revenir à cette base là qui existait
dans la politique puis les gens ils ont
envie d'en parler ils ont envie d'en
parler intelligemment faut juste à nous
de faire cette effort-là
de la batterie tel type de personnel
profil de personnes vote tel
pasteur
oui mais en même temps si ça existe pour
vrai dans le sens où on a reçu pendant
la campagne électorale justement on a
reçu un spécialiste que lui il étudie
les comportements électoraux et puis
il est capable de prédire quand même de
manière assez assez efficace
dépendamment de outabit de ton âge de
quelqu'un
de prédire de manière assez juste pour
qui tu vas voter c'est un peu
décourageant ça peut être très
intéressant parce qu'on se dit dans le
fond j'ai choisi de voter pour qui je
vote je suis déterminé à voter mais si
on peut pitié souvent ça crée déjà de
distorsion de parler à quelqu'un qui qui
vient de de certains background puis
lutte leur parle d'un parti x puis c'est
comme si tu parles du diable vers ça tu
parles à quelqu'un d'autre moi j'ai j'ai
les deux dans mon entourage certaines
personnes avec qui tu vas parler les
réseaux sociaux parce que les réseaux
sociaux c'est coupé au couteau même dans
la vie
j'ai un ami qui
il parle de François Legault comme si
c'était la
pire personne sur la terre c'est quand
même un être humain
à des gens qui c'est
belles tenues
des gens qui sont pas dans la réalité
nananactions immense que si justement on
va parler aux gens directement dans le
blanc des yeux qu'on explique dans notre
affaire puis non non c'est réaliste ce
qu'on pense puis ça peut ramener un peu
le balancier
tout est tout est comme
c'est noir ou blanc
les gens sont aussi dans leur chambre
déco puis au delà des réseaux sociaux tu
sais fais que c'est là qu'il faut faire
l'effort d'aller vers des gens qu'on
pense que c'est juste impossible qui
nous écoutent faut pas se limiter à leur
profil donc c'est sûr que c'est pas nous
le spa qu'avec celle-là qui sont qui ont
l'air plus d'une
puis c'est sûr que les gens aussi il y a
un aspect où il se représente par
exemple moi si je me suis présenté je
viens d'une famille qui aime pas la
politique tout ça mais j'ai jamais été
comme dans les milieux tout le temps des
minorités tu sais j'avais des amis
évidemment qui qui ont des noms de
famille à consonance étrangères et tout
ça mais les jeunes filles qui disent des
jeunes filles comme beaucoup plus jeune
que moi mais qui qui viennent de famille
immigrantes et tout ça puis qui se
reconnaissent puis ça vient leur parler
c'est ça aussi des fois c'est comme un
raccourci c'est peut-être que je pense
pas comme elle mais les gens ils ont
besoin aussi de se voir de se
reconnaître c'est pas non plus
ultra mauvaise c'est bien de de c'est
pour ça qu'il faut avoir une Assemblée
nationale qui soit représentative de la
population pour que les gens sentent que
ok c'est à moi je peux me retrouver là
c'est des gens qui qui sont pas loin de
nous et aussi d'aller sur le terrain
mais que ça allez sur le terrain tous
les politiciens dit ça des fois j'aime
pas ça ça a l'air qui chez Johanna
il faut absolument pas moi je pense pas
qu'on va tomber dans le piège parce que
nous on nous écoute puis nous regardent
puis nous c'est nous on a mis beaucoup
Québec soldat des gardes des gardes de
fous pour s'assurer qu'on tombe pas dans
le piège où est-ce que les les gens au
Parlement se séparent du parti puis
partir les membres sont là c'est eux qui
ont exigé puis un comité avec des
membres de où est-ce qu'on va aller puis
comment on va parler ça va être présenté
sûrement le pour à l'automne fait ça ça
je pense que c'est la bonne chose à
faire c'est beaucoup de travail c'est
beaucoup mais c'est beaucoup plus
nourrissant puis ça donne un sens à la
politique qui n'est pas juste un jeu
comme un jeu de sport qui qui fait que
sur la partie que j'agis la politique
ça fait quoi
il faut que ça se repose c'est obligé
obliger obliger là moi j'arrête pas de
me le répéter avec mon chameau vous
comprenez des vacances faut qu'on prenne
des vacances moi ça me prend des jours
avant de décrocher tu finis par
décrocher mais là par exemple on a
terminé
la semaine passée le Parlement mais que
là on va dans notre côté fait que là il
y a des affaires qui se passe dans mon
compte des rencontres avec des
organismes des groupes des il fait beau
dans les parcs fait que d'être présent
c'est important les gens demandent ça
puis après ça la Saint Jean aussi au
parc laurier j'ai deux événements un à
23h24 avec les jeunes de wikobe le 24
puis le 23 c'est le comité qui organise
la Fête nationale puis après ça après ça
je vois je vais aller je sais pas encore
où dans un chalet j'ai le chalet d'amis
où on va en famille puis me reposer
pendant le mois d'une partie du mois de
juillet puis après ça je repars faire
une tournée du Québec mais pas pour
faire du tourisme
pour aller à la rencontre de nos membres
merci beaucoup
fan avec vous merci merci beaucoup
vraiment